when did you kind of
start to become like serious when it
came to just the weed [ __ ] because
obviously it all starts from a place
where it's trapping
and then it evolves
i was like i gotta do this you know no
matter what it is from
doing what i was doing when i was
younger to
getting into the dispensary stuff to you
know when i was just working at a
dispensary you were doing security at a
dispensary or something right i got
hired as like um
kind of like an intake person like you
know people show up i check their doctor
letter and make sure it's official call
the doctor check buzz them into the main
area where they go by the weed and they
move me into like we actually like sell
the wheat i was a bud tender and then
went from there to a buyer and that's
when i really fell in love with the [ __ ]
talking to all the vendors and the
growers and seeing different strains and
whatnot then to a manager running the
shop and
it's funny because people would come in
fans of the music and couldn't believe i
just worked there they thought i owned
it
and so so people would be [ __ ] with
your music come to the dispensary and
then they see you and they'd be like oh
this burner spot but you were just that
was my shop i just was [ __ ] working
there because i loved it and as my music
career got bigger and bigger i had to
commit less and less time to working
there and eventually just figured out
how to do my own thing you know so